this past weekend okay we got audio
we got the video rolling all right guys
we're gonna start right here today found
this online this
this looks kind of the zombie Anse music
right here
it's called emotion 11 I thought it was
kind of like whimsical and and kind of
wizardly and uplifting and wild and
everything I thought it was a little bit
of like a something you might hear if
you were leaving this universe and
heading into the next one because
today's September 11th you know I know
we have a lot going on but right now I
just want to take I just want to take 20
seconds of silence just to remember just
as a maza
moment of silence for September 11th so
here we go
all right I appreciate you guys you guys
just you know kind of going through that
it's September 11th I'm not going to
talk a ton about it you know but
certainly you know it's one of those
things that pops in your head man it's
here it's here every year
I remember I was in the airport this is
a few years ago at Los Angeles Airport I
didn't even realize it was September
11th you know and no shame on us if we
do or if we don't recognize it it's
coming you know because I mean we're
living our lives and that's what people
who lost their lives in September that's
exactly what they would be doing you
know they'd be living their life you
know I mean that's that's what we're
here to do we're here to celebrate
living even though we switch the song
out today for that song which was called
emotion 11 by Nicholas Gustafson and I
looked for it looked for something that
I thought was kind of you know that
would be you know that elevator music
you might hear on the way up to heaven
you know something that's kind of
whimsical and wispy and like anything is
you know anything anything is possible
you know something kind of exciting and
everything I thought of that music but
years ago I was in the airport I was in
Los Angeles International Airport flying
us somewhere it was September 11th and
it was the time in between the exact
minute in between when the airplanes
that hit the two Twin Towers and they
came over the loudspeaker in the airport
and I mean this is Los Angeles Airport
there's thousands tens of thousands of
people in there bustling and running
around and they said right now we want
to observe a minute of stillness and
silence for 9/11 and everybody stopped
and it was pretty mesmerizing it was
like because I mean your plane wasn't
gonna leave because everybody was
stopped everything was too every there
was no so you had like this free minute
in this extremely busy space where
everybody was still and silent and it
was really it was it was pretty that was
a kind of an emotional moment and it was
just captivating to see to see everybody
slow it down and stop and just
have a moment of peace in you know in
just a morning of anarchy at the Los
Angeles International Airport but I'm
gonna say happy September 11th guys I
don't mean that in a condescending way I
just mean it in we're here we're living
and we need to do you know just continue
to move onward and do the best that we
can with our lives and I'm sure that's
what anybody who's you know milling
about and the great beyond is wanting us
to do so I'm happy to be here I'm happy
to be here with you guys on Monday
September 11 2017 I was in Austin I was
in Austin Texas this past weekend and I
just want to thank everybody that came
out I mean I was really just dumbfounded
by by Austin man it's all it's cool I
mean Texas is a cool state Texas is a
kind of place where it feels like as
long as you get your work done you do
what you want to do you say what you
want to say but you get up every day and
you do your job whatever it is it seems
like one of the last places on earth or
in America where I've noticed that we
don't want any slackers around here it
was just this vibe that I got in the air
you know in Texas you come here I mean
it doesn't matter if you're a reader a
writer a rodeo man if he's out there
checking animals being one of them
people that checks animals for uh you
know birth or lumps or something
sometimes you see those videos where men
have them they're putting their animals
inside of a calf's butter and the
ovaries trying to get a baby out if you
do that if you're a doctor a lawyer a
shepherd anything as long as you come
here and you do your job then that's
fine
that's fine that's the Texas Way just
had this vibe about it and it was really
cool I mean really diverse diverse you
know schools of thought
Austin's amazing if you haven't been
went to this place called Barton Springs
where you could just it's like this they
like kind of caged up this river you
know so I've caged things in my life
I've caged cats when we were young we
caught a bunch of cats me and my buddy
Danny and he's
too bad he was born with thumb not
cerebral palsy but just just kind of
neck his neck had some kind of just kind
of you know it wasn't really his neck
wasn't strong he had a limp neck you
know a lot of people your neck holds you
straight up but my boy Danny his neck
didn't want him to be straight up his
neck like to rest and yeah you know he
was always kind of just you know
fighting to keep his head up he was just
always battling gravity with his head
you know but anyhow we uh we used to get
dang it I lost my train of thought Oh
were we talking about we're talking
about gravity no we're talking about
animals
oh we're talking about swimming we used
to cage up cats and we talked about
caged animals cuz somebody caged up a
river there in Austin Texas and they
call it Barton Springs and that's
amazing to me when you were an eight
somebody basically what somebody did was
I guess they have a river and somebody
trapped it like you know you put a dam
to trap a river on one side well
somebody came back and put a dam on the
other side and they trapped it and they
caught on they caught a river somebody
caged up a piece of nature you know it's
like if you go out in your yard right
now you throw a big net over a tree and
you tie the net down on all four corners
that trees not gonna be able to grow
it's gonna be you turn and start growing
downwards you know if you want to be a
tree catcher a tree cager well somebody
did this with a river and it's beautiful
out there you go in there's hills and
there's people sunbathing and legal
breasts it's legal breast environment
where they have a law in Texas where if
a man has his shirt off if a man can
have his nipples out then a woman can
have her nipples out that's a dual
nipple state and you see we were out
there and we saw some we saw some
fair-market titties boy we sure did we
saw some fair-market titties out there
and some decent titties you know
sometimes you think when you go to these
outdoor environments where there's tit
where there's breasts or Hooters or
Hogan's or you know fun sacks or
whatever you want to call them man you
know them them dang milk rabbits you
know some people if you think if you're
gonna see them outdoors then they're
gonna be not they're gonna be kind of
dirty or dusty looking titties because
me and my same buddy with the you know
with not much of a neck on him with that
you know kind of that weeping willow of
a neck my boy Danny we used to go by the
rest area and we would look at a lot of
people would meet up behind the rest
area and you know do drugs and then do
have drug-induced sexual activity and we
would go out there and watch them
sometimes from far away you know we were
still at that age we didn't want to get
that close because we were sex made us
pretty nervous as children you know when
you're when you're children you see two
people beatin their bodies into each
other for joy it doesn't make much sense
you know when you see two people from
far away just slamming their crotches
into each other you kind of just think
they're the worst dancers you know so as
children we weren't you know super close
on them to see you know we're still a
little bit weary it wasn't like when
you're like 15 we're like oh man how
close can I get you know maybe I can get
downwind of this activity and catch a
hit you know catch a catch a long hit
off this activity out there the
sensuality but we weren't feeling like
that we were still at that age where we
want you know we wanted to just kind of
see what was going on but me and uh me
and you know Danny would get over by the
rest area you know we have binoculars or
we only had one set of binoculars and
then somebody would have a magnifying
glass and in hindsight that wasn't very
effective but you know [ __ ] we were kids
dude you know most of the most of the
[ __ ] we were doing wasn't ineffective
you know children do a lot of
ineffective [ __ ] so we get out there and
we'd see some titties out there by the
rest area you know we see drug-induced
you know sensual activity and all of
that and a lot of those breasts were
dirtier on the men and women you'd see
you know just nude bodies that were so
covered in dirt you didn't know what
ethnicity someone was you know so pretty
interesting but out of this Barton
Springs they're in Austin Texas it was
you know just peaceful
it was kind of like what you'd imagine
if clean people were behind a rest area
just having a good time and listening to
music go and swim and had a diving board
right into this caged up river and it
was just man its sheer joy out there the
children can go you know in France
children see titties all the time
breasts all the time you know nippled uh
you know nippled [ __ ] dam feeders
female feeders children see them all the
time and it's only in America where we
have children so gun-shy about breasts
about tits so it's it's nice to be in an
environment where people aren't that
gun-shy about it where you know a man or
a woman can have their breasts out and
everybody's not freaking out and that's
Barton Springs over there in Austin
Texas if you get a chance I recommend
that you check it out I'm thinking also
of I know that they got a new hurricane
that's come through irma beaten up down
there and in the Gulf in the Gulf of
montanta Florida you know obviously
thinking about those people and
wondering what lives are like for them I
actually got a call I'll play it really
fast as someone that came in somebody
hit the hotline and the hotline you can
address anything in the show so we got a
call that came in from the hotline from
Florida let's take a DAB off of that
right here I'm calling from Boca Raton
Florida right in the middle of hurricane
um and it just cut off like that so who
knows what happened to her actually hey
she could have taken a front to the she
could have taken a front to the frickin
sound hole you know but that was it
you know we asked some callers to call
in about Florida see what was going on
that's the one call that we got it was
from Devon obviously who called in
obviously under the influence of alcohol
and and maybe hurricane water and uh and
who knows what happened her but I pray
that she's safe she literally just got
cut off eleven seconds into that call
not by me
the call just came in cut off but yeah
thinking about those people
thinking about people in Harvey you know
it's interesting it's like when one
another natural disaster happens in our
minds especially with the news and stuff
today we kind of just move right on it's
like oh what's next you know it's
interesting on television you start
watching Florida so much you forget that
people have just gone through in Texas
this in Texas you forget that it's 9/11
today because otherwise the news would
be building up about that you know
they'd be covering stories about that or
you know checking in with people and
it's just uh there's a lot going on
we're living in a busy time there's a
lot of excitement and I don't mean
excitement that it's all positive but
excitement you know there can be
negative excitement you know like if
they have a serial killer in your town
yeah it's not positive excitement but
it's exciting you know it's exciting to
sit in your breakfast nook in the
morning and eat eat a little bit of all
Apple Jacks and know that they might
have a man with a dagger or something
waiting for you somewhere you know it's
like there's a little bit of there's a
little bit of excitement in the air so I
think that that's what's going on out
there but I appreciate everybody that
came out in Austin we have some patreon
up patreon.com slash Theo von if you
want to show your support I appreciate
that as well
people have been and and we're just
getting into that we reaching out to
those people this week what else last
week I had people call in it was Labor
Day and I had people calling about jobs
jobs that they had different jobs and
usually I wait to play calls to later in
the show but I just want to play this
guy's call that came in because it puts
some things into perspective let's say
that this fella put things in a
perspective for me listen to this guy
yeah Theo you've talking about that job
yeah he's talking about bad job because
I had talking about at the end of the
podcast last week got talked about some
jobs that I had just referenced in labor
day so that's what he's talking about
onward when I got out of high school I
went to work for the city and I worked
at a sewer plant
and so you know all the detergent [ __ ]
would get all clogged up and he said
turds bro man I you know what I love
when people say turds people don't say
that enough and I was driving through El
Paso Texas one time on my way to
University of Arizona and I saw a turd a
human piece of you know just body dirt
but you know but foreign old lunch just
fly through the air across the
interstate right across the front of my
window and you might think oh that's
crazy dude
you didn't see a turd fly across the
interstate in front of your car well
guess what I've never seen it again
and I've never thought something was a
turd so that makes me think in hindsight
that if I saw it then that's what it was
I'm not just you know I've seen birds go
by I know what other things are so I
know when somebody's humming feces past
me but anyhow I didn't mean to interrupt
your bud let's go let's listen to the
rest of this story okay go so they had
to have somebody drive around in a boat
out in the sewer pond to stir everything
up whoo whoo whoo I'm the captain now
can you even imagine can you imagine
that you are the [ __ ] boat captain
deon word and yes there was a time that
I went to work fun time really drunk and
I did fall out of the boat and so people
to ask me about my job and I would tell
him it was just [ __ ] because it
literally was [ __ ] so anybody who thinks
their job is bad
think about being the boat driver at the
ship pot Wow so just want to start you
know what I wanted to kick us off right
there so if your day is already you know
gone to [ __ ] well guess what you just
won your day back because that man right
there they just called in okay that man
was operating a tugboat out in a doodoo
River think about that think about the
next time you all make make make
brownies with your bottom and think
about it going out into the distance and
then think about some man being out
there boating through it and I'm not
trying to be nasty this morning I was
trying to put our lives in a perspective
and I appreciate your call because not a
lot of men is brave enough to say
they've been out there you know kayaking
through Dukey and this man is saying
that and I appreciate that it means a
lot dude and that puts it that puts it
into perspective you know yeah can you
paddle over there yes oh really got a
couple of uh yeah oh yeah a couple uh I
mean can you even imagine that getting
over there with an oar breaking up the
rig I mean that guy
so anyway is your day that today huh
you're gonna have to get are you gonna
take a risk of falling into a you know
pure imagination it's like that Charlie
and the Chocolate Factory the part where
uh Gustav ash lop or whatever that guy's
name is yakky doc Alice Guan Snoop aqus
or whatever I mean like the hello and
then he falls in it's like that that guy
went through it like I went through it
for us
so what's your day like huh I want you
to retake a look at your day right now
does it entail that at all does it
entail be you be in the ferry captain on
a doodoo battleship if it doesn't then
it sounds like you're gonna be doing
pretty well today and I appreciate you
being here with me yeah Austin was great
I'll be in Cleveland this coming weekend
so you know that so you can be prepared
for that if you live out in Cleveland or
have been out there I'll be at the
hilarities comedy club so come out and
see me this this week this week and it
makes me think I had if I had a fan that
showed up our friend that showed up in
in Texas this past week and I've been
asked this a bunch about just how I got
into comedy and what I did and what made
me want to do it
stuff like that and then a call came in
a call came in about kind of something
along those lines so I'm gonna play that
right now this is from Indiana onward
hey Theo uh just want to say I love the
show I'd like to say that I'm 18 you
know I'm trying to figure life out right
now I don't know if I should leave my
family and go pursue a music career I
mean you don't have to make the decision
for me I just feel like I have something
to say to the world but I I'm afraid of
being you know without security you know
on my own I mean I'm kind of on my own
right now but I don't know maybe you can
help me thanks man
I want to thank you for calling I
appreciate that from Indiana Indiana
also where the Ku Klux Klan started and
I'm not trying to raise any controversy
or anything but I'm from Louisiana
we get blamed a lot for that I just
wanted to at least just bring that up I
appreciate you calling man I could hear
your voice like you know you're at that
age where you trying to decide you know
you're figuring it out and let me just
you know I don't really have any advice
from you because my advice usually don't
take any advice but I can tell I can
share with you that you have time like
it might be hard to realize at 18 but
you have time you can make a few choices
you could go into the military you could
you could have a family you know and
still do things later you could go into
the military and then still pursue a
couple job opportunities that do you
have time so it's a it's a at Lee it's
at least awesome to hear that you're
interested in what's next for you you
know what's on the forefront of your
battleground you know and I I have uh I
wasn't sure if I wanted to move out to
Los Angeles and how good one of my best
friends his father who's probably maybe
about seven years old and one of the
best and one of the best and worst
dancers I've ever met from Greenville
Mississippi he said I asked him I was
knurl I didn't know I said I don't know
what I want to do and he had always
wanted to he tall he had always been a
writer but he'd always want to really
pursue it you know when he never gotten
around to it as much as he wanted to
he said man he said if you don't go now
and chase your dream he said you might
never will and some of you guys are
thinking well that's not really correct
grammar well that's what he said I mean
this beautiful gentleman was from
Mississippi and he said you might never
will and that's all it took for me it
took somebody saying that look if you
don't get out there and give it a shot
you'll never know and I'll say these
talked about your family your family
will always be there they're gonna go
through things they're gonna love you no
matter what you know they'll be there
when you get back some of them might be
on drugs someone might not be whatever
but they'll always be there so you know
I would if if it continues to plague you
that you're not sure then you can check
it out you can always go back it's at
home won't change that much you know and
if it does change it'll change for the
better because I believe that change is
always for the better what about these
categories and I was thinking about this
like so irma hits this and I appreciate
you calling man and best of luck you
know it's your own personal choice but
the fact that you're thinking about it
is important you know because you're
thinking you're thinking man if you
start from if you're thinking about
you're gonna do well you're gonna do
well let's think about this with
categories right these categories of
these storms I'm all over the place I'm
all over the place we got a lot going on
today right we got hurricanes we got 911
we got you know yeah people you have
people bass-fishing out in duty lakes
you know and I'm thinking about like
they do categories for different storms
I wish they did that for your family
don't you because I'll tell you right
now I'm one of my sisters category three
undeniable the other sister
oh you think God would give me only a
category two no she's a category four
gale-force sure I mean it hit you so
hard you can't close your eyes for a
couple hours you know she comes in hot
she comes in hot but then she got some
loaves she got some loaves so I just
think would be great if we could
categorize our family members as to what
they were Oh uncle Danny ah dude we
haven't see
in a couple years we assume he's
probably a category-2 you know out in
Key West but my grandfather Oh barely
with us anymore as a category one
yeah we're just he's doing good though
he got a new roommate over at the home
but wouldn't it be great if you just had
categories for your family I wish they
had it I wish they had it you would just
get an idea I always thought it would be
good if they had pamphlets for when you
meet somebody to give you a pamphlet
people like well what do you like and
you like it I don't really have time to
tell you but check out the pamphlet you
know and if you like what you see then
you know follow me on social media I
think it'd be great if everybody had a
pamphlet because otherwise you got to go
milling around you got to go you know
snooping around and seeing what's going
on it can get a little bit tricky but if
they had that pamphlet oh they had that
pamphlet what else you know I'm feeling
I'm feeling excited about this week I
went watch some music today when I got
home I flew back from Austin football is
back so suddenly and whatever has been
bogging you as a man or as a football
fan suddenly at all starts to drift away
a little bit I bet there's even some
relief a little bit of relief for people
who are going through these storms you
know to be bottled away in a hotel far
from their home there's a little relief
to know that for this weekend they got
they got a little bit of football you
know because I it just there's something
as a man if you're a sport watching man
it's soothing to you you know I mean
sure it's Monday sure you got your
workweek ahead but look outside of your
boat what's out there
do do rivers I don't think so not
everybody's a ship boat captain you know
so let's just be let's be gracious that
we're not that today and let's be
gracious that their ship boat captains
up there who are willing to call in and
share what that's like as well I want to
thank everybody one of my videos on
YouTube got up to 150,000 views that's
the white privilege vide
if you want to check that out it's on
YouTube and that clip I talk about white
privilege you know and you hear a lot
about white privilege and I know it
exists you know I'm not denying that but
I know that I did not feel it and I did
not see it and some of my black friends
will say well you know you just you
don't know you know like you don't know
what it's like to be black and to not
have that but I know what it's like to
be white and not have it you know I
remember going to the principal's office
are going to the the office and trying
to get financial aid for college and
they had all the programs but not for a
white guy
then everything special for the poor
white kid everything you had to be black
or Native American or Pacific Islander
what is that what does that even do
Pacific Islander surfers you telling me
surfers are getting special treatment or
getting opportunity where I live in
Louisiana we're pretty much landlocked
unless you got a river surfer you know
where somebody's surfing at home in
their tub you know it's on a small board
so you know I remember one time I've you
know I was like what do you have is
there anything for me is there anything
special I can apply for and she said uh
no we got this and I said she said it's
for black people for black children and
I said well you know I can't do that she
goes we'll come back when you're black
that's what this lady told me this old
lady working in the in the financial aid
counselor office come back when I'm back
come on
so you know if you get a chance to check
out that clip it's a short clip but it's
just something you know I'm trying to
I'm trying to you know I get nervous
sometimes to share some of my feelings
especially these days you know everybody
wants to make it out like every white
person's had the greatest existence in
the world but of course I realize that
there are elements that are deeply
embedded in our society you know in the
ways that we think in the histories of
the ways that we think in our economy in
the ways
that everything has been structured and
and maybe it's easy to just use a
blanket term like white privilege but
everybody's different and when I hear
that term just thrown around when I hear
it thrown around a lot it feels to me
condescending it makes me feel like I
was in the same social and financial
life structure as you know little Carl
Fauntleroy the third you know William or
you know fancy font low pants the third
and I wasn't he had conditioner he had
probably hair conditioner at his house
you know and he probably got to bathe by
himself and I know these are just small
ideas and you know but I'm just saying I
remember bathing the four kids that I
didn't know one time whoa what was that
and they weren't even white it's just I
just think we got to be specific you
know by being blanket it doesn't address
by being and using a blanket term it
doesn't address and I know I'm getting
all off on a tangent here but it's tough
these days it's tough these days to have
any sort of a feeling that seems to go
against some of of the status quo
sometimes even just to have a question
that goes against the status quo and I
think that these days you know you got
to be specific because by being blanket
with a term like white privilege it
doesn't address the the different
inequalities because you're assuming
that everyone is the same and that's
that's not true there's a lot of
different levels within white people
there's everyone you know you know me I
mean I feel like a million a million
special and things had to happen for me
to get to where I am at in my life today
and not things that I did either I'm not
saying that I'm talking about just
unique opportunities or care that I
received from peeps trainers that I
didn't
expect and there wasn't white privilege
one things that happen because I was
white surely it was just net just the
nature of people wanting to be good to
other people you know but but yeah so I
guess have a lot of feelings wrapped
around that and look I don't have to be
right about those feelings you know some
of them can just be feelings maybe
they're not right but I do have a lot of
thoughts I guess you know and it's an
interesting topic and so I'm trying to
explore it more on stage so if you get a
chance check out that uh the white
privilege clip on YouTube share it it's
picking up some steam and I want people
to see it because I I'm just gonna keep
working in that realm and trying to make
you know find some light and what were
some of the darker days in my time
growing up in white poverty you know and
in poverty in general you know that's
what I'm saying is that when poor is
poor you know if you want to talk about
green privilege I knew people that had
that but that white privilege I didn't
see that you know I didn't see it in my
life and I'd love to go back I'd love to
get some reparations for that you know
sign me up some of these people going to
these fancy games and sit in these
Suites and eating crab meat you know and
people having uh teddy bears that
actually have fur on them you know and
I'm hugging that bear at night they
don't have any fur you know and I'm not
complaining but I am explaining you know
I'm just sick of you know they don't
think a poor white person is gonna make
it out of that environment and get out
there and get up to you know to hear
where I am at today even though it's
nowhere special but being able to have a
voice and say what I want onstage well I
disagree with that you know I'm not
gonna not live my truth because it
doesn't fit in with what what this
narrative sometimes is it's out there in
the world you know that every poor white
person has to be a redneck or every poor
white person has to be an idiot you know
or every poor white person you know like
I don't know what it's like to be black
it's true I'll never know you know and
and I don't claim to you know I try to
empathize with people that had a tough
time for sure and I know I saw a lot of
my black friends growing up have a tough
time you know I mean I did I mean it was
at a time when there weren't any wealthy
black people the only wealthy black
people I ever saw were athletes or the
dudes on coming to America you know and
that was a movie but that was it and I'm
not saying that to be mean I'm just
saying that as to what my and what what
I saw you know so I have a lot of you
know but but also a black person will
never know what it's like to be poor and
white you know to grow up in similar
type poverty but to to to to be white
you know it's like rich people don't
look at you like they want a hell it's
not you know it's like this is a special
white van coming around once a week and
dropping off white [ __ ] White's you know
white growth white opportunity you know
if anything they look at you like oh how
this guy [ __ ] it up you know he's white
he don't have anything uh I don't want
any of that you know it's like you got
money aids when you're white it's like
you got money aids people look at you
like oh I don't like don't put the money
by him he gonna [ __ ] it up so but that
clip kind of gets into that now you know
and I'm trying to expound more of that
in my comedy because I want to I want to
try and share my truth I don't want to
try and at least share my truth in an
environment where if other people want
to respond to it then that's fine and
I'm always open to learn you know I
don't have to be right but but I can be
vocal even if I'm wrong along the way
you know so anyhow I appreciate any
sharing you can do with that real quick
I want to throw a word out for laughable
and this is not they're not paying me
for this but I like their app if you
have an iPhone you should go down
the laughable app and you can use it to
listen all of your podcasts from now on
it's the best rated podcast app in the
App Store
what makes laughable unique is you can
subscribe not just a podcast series but
also directly to me and any other
comedians you enjoy listening to on
podcasts once you subscribe laughable
will keep you current on all the
podcasts that that comedian or that I as
a guest or as a host or as a guest host
go on so you can keep tabs if if you
like listening to me you like listening
to someone you can follow them and you
can hear whenever they go on another
podcast as well
iPhone users go to laughable com slash
download or search for a laughable in
the App Store it's a great app and I
totally recommend it and if you like the
podcast tell your friends you know let
them know what's going on we're doing
some good stuff here I know we're gonna
try to reach out to inmates soon and get
an inmate's corner in here and see
what's going on out there in the
correctional facility and we're gonna
keep the vibe going and we're gonna keep
things going out here another vibe
sounds weirder than what that means but
you know but I'm just a [ __ ] boat
captain man I'm just a [ __ ] boat captain
so let's hit another caller right here
we had people call in about their jobs
we're talking about Labor Day and one of
the things like you know when I think
about 911 and I think about still being
alive I think about like what does it
mean to be alive
you know because you sometimes you know
you'll see you know you'll see tributes
to 911 or you if you're if you have the
opportunity to be in New York and go see
the memorial there it's amazing it's
breathtaking it's beautiful it's got
that it's got the same as the the wall
that's in Washington DC and I don't want
to you know say the wrong name of the
wall but it's the it's the wall that I
believe has the names of many of the
soldiers that that died in Vietnam I
believe or it could be world war two I'm
not sure but there's a wall there that
you know just memorializes a lot of
soldiers and ma'am being at those places
is just it's it's heavy it's real
makes you think about life you know and
sometimes we romanticize life when we
think about one when we were thinking
about 9/11 or where or we're thinking
about you know it's Veterans Day we
romanticize life but life I mean we're
just out here with each other you know
we're out here we're an 18 year old boy
wondering if he should you know chase a
dream if he should move out west for a
little bit you know we're a guy who
showed up to work hung over and fell
into a into a stool bath you know and
you got that dip you know who took that
dip you know we're we're just people we
wake up we might have problems we might
not have problems you know we might be
in love who might not be in love you
know we might be searching for something
but not even sure if what we're
searching for is what's best for us you
know it's not like life is sometimes
it's you know we were romanticized and I
do anyway when I think about these
certain you know on days like 9/11
I'm romanticized with life it's so and
it is precious it's an amazing gift it's
it's something that we can't even
quantify you know the scientists sure
they can get on these molecules on
something but I like to think that life
hasn't made up of mostly magic you know
and I don't need to know all the answers
you know I just need to be out here and
know that I have the ability to stay to
be out here living it but yeah it's just
us man it's just us making decisions
figuring it out that's what we're doing
and I appreciate you guys hitting this
hotline and calling in and being a part
of this together the hotline number is
nine eight five six six four nine five
zero three and this guy had a phone call
I already listened to it once most of
these have already listened to once some
are cut off right in the beginning if I
really think it's gonna be cool so I can
listen to it with you guys the first
time but this one this call is a game II
team so let's listen to this gentleman
that called in about jobs hey Theo Tim
from Tiffany calling again this is Tim
from Tennessee
onward Tim I just want to tell you about
a job that I had when I was about 18 I
worked at a Kroger
you know it wasn't that bad of a job but
you know I worked in the deli onward and
it was mostly with a bunch I mean you
know just this old hardened women um oh
yeah I like an old hardened woman hey
give me that are a Maureen we got a
couple of we got a couple of uh we've
got a couple of butts we've got a couple
of roast butts over there where's the
Martin Donna where's the mutton oh well
and they're always gossiping like Oh
[ __ ] cherlene was supposed to do -
damn crab cakes and she's out there with
her [ __ ] husband and she don't even
like him sorry brother homeward and you
know they told me a lot of stories about
their eggs husbands and things like that
so that was that was pretty entertaining
but um my favorite part of that job was
probably you know all the all the foods
that I that I stole and I ate you know I
ate a lot of fried chicken I worked in
daily making fried chicken so I ate a
lot of that and I also ate a lot of
those like tons of those cookies that
you know you're supposed to give off to
the children but on hey hey that's it
man you know if I'm working at a deli
what do you think I'm doing you think
I'm back there - slicing meat for
whoever's buying it
oh I'm hiding prosciutto in my cheeks
dude
oh I'm stuffing a couple of ounces of
boar head right up my freakin bunghole
I'm drug mule in a couple of [ __ ]
sliced pieces of honey baked out of that
[ __ ] dude I used to wash dishes at this
fancy restaurant they had cheeses in
that place that I've never even heard of
I mean cheese is that you had to have a
date I mean your tongue had to know
acrobatics to even say the names of
these cheeses and I worked there and I
was doing dishwashing and even the wall
even the water I washed dishes with I
think was was charcoal filtered or
something I mean it was nice place and I
remember I would collect these these
half a sandwiches and pieces
sandwiches come back there with this
cheese on them this gray area nuh bruss
broths brass Farah different cheeses you
know and I would collect a man I would
save all these cheese's and then I could
get me a piece of bread and I'd take
half-eaten pieces of cheese off of
people's sandwiches and at the end of
the night it had me a beautiful little
just unpronounceable cheese treat and
sometimes you got to treat yourself so I
understand what you're doing back there
in the deli you know one piece of
chicken for Danny and one piece of
chicken for daddy let's keep it moving
yeah my my least favorite part though
was probably this there's this gay boy
that would here always
I'm not laughing because it's a gay boy
I'm laughing how he said it though you
know kind of flirt with me even though
he knew I wasn't gay but he still kind
of continued to flirt with me and and he
would he would always kind of like hide
behind the deli counter and and all
sneaky-like and and he would jump out
and scare me lonely mean and that is
something you know what cuz I think a
lot of gay boys they like if they see a
straight man get scared because they
feel like there's a momentary
disconnection from a man in his spirit
where they could jump in there you know
they can jump in there and get at your
heart and get at you you know your butt
and in your love nest and everything
because that's the thing sometimes you
just gotta shake somebody off of there
off of their emotional footing and if
their emotional footing is heterosexual
you got to shake them off of it and then
you can slip in there you know and slide
that that mental spirit dick into them
first and then come and prosper
physically after so I see that trick
it's a gay trick you know and that's
fine nothing wrong with that I'm not
saying there's anything wrong with that
it's just a pickup move that I think a
lot of you know as this young gay boy
he's probably trying to get up in a year
you know he's probably trying to he's
probably envious of that chicken you
hidin in your cheeks
you know he wants you to hide his little
bit uh his little you know his little
lost slice of uh his slice a hard gay
cornbread up in your mouth probably you
know so that's truly beautiful man I
respect respect both you guys for
you know freeze-tag back there behind
the meat counter let's hear a little bit
more of this beautiful story so uh I
didn't really like that also also there
was a cute office uh can hear all of it
again but he still kind of continued to
flirt with me and and he would he would
always kind of like hide behind the deli
counter and and all sneaky-like and and
he would jump out and scare me was lots
of meat so uh I didn't really like that
also also there was a there was a
different gay man who would he would
always try to fix my clothes for me like
you know I could just my collar or zip
up my jacket things like that so that
kind of made me uncomfortable but uh but
anyways that was a job that I had
thanks for the podcast man you have a
good'n
keep it up yeah and that's more of the
motherly gay man you know and I think
that that's nice to have I mean it sound
like at least you had people that were
loving you back there excuse me at least
you had people that were loving you you
know at least you had a beautiful little
gay boy to jump out from behind a meat
wheel or whatever and spook you you know
you back there cutting into some exotic
beef so some London broil and then next
thing you know you got a Randy little
Davey I imagine his name is something
like davier you know salty William or
something and next thing you know you
got salty William just living right
there on the on the doorstep of your
shoulder and that's beautiful man and
then you got the other guy the older
gentleman the older gay gentleman coming
there fixing your clothes it's not like
you living in the lap of luxury man it
sound like you live in high high on the
hog but that's what life is
that's what life is you know it's a man
named Tim in Tennessee hiding chicken
and his cheeks and getting approached by
younger and older game in it's a guy
driving a [ __ ] wheeler floating [ __ ]
boat that's what life is
that's what we're doing
you know that's what we're doing well
we're Lisa and that's it that's what it
is it's just it's it's life oh you got a
do everyday is get up and show up for it
you got to take action every day you got
to take action you got to show up and
meet life halfway and life will meet you
with amazing things amazing things it
could be anything it could be anything
and that's what that's what that's what
the gift of life is it's possibility its
possibility if you show up every day if
you can find a way I know you having a
tough day I know you don't want to go to
work again
I know it's 6:45 or 810 in the morning I
know you're running late but oh well
what are you gonna do about that nothing
but what are you gonna do about yourself
you show up you show up you change your
attitude and you say I ain't falling off
this [ __ ] boat today um doc captain now
that's what it's about yes that is what
it's about I had a text come in some
people text the hotline as well you can
text the hotline and this was from
Poplar Bluff Minnesota Minnesota is one
of the big 50 states it's where the um
it's where the Mississippi River begins
at Lake Itasca Park and I met a
beautiful young lady named Melinda one
time and she took me there and we sat
out there and talked and had a nice
coffee and I could jump from one side of
the Mississippi to the other so that was
cool you want to talk about a [ __ ] River
go check in with the Mississippi down
here in Louisiana boy it's 90% bowel
water okay but let's hear this text I'm
going to read it to you hey yo Theo do
you think Tarzan was a virgin and you
misspelled virgin you spelled a V er GI
in when he met Jane do you think Tarzan
was a virgin when he met Jane or you
think he was
eating gorilla cheeks and I guess that
means having sex with gorillas and if so
is that where AIDS started okay so I'll
tell you this man I mean Tarzan if you
don't know Tarzan Tarzan was this it was
his character I think in the early 1900s
that went into that was raised in the
woods by Apes and in the story the Apes
don't even exist you know the story I
think I'm trying to remember who even
wrote that the story of Tarzan the Apes
don't even exist a fictional character
and edgar burrows and actually and if
you know this but edgar burrows also
wrote John Carter he also wrote John
Carter which is that Disney movie that
that came out a few years ago that the
guy from Friday Night Lights played the
lead in anyhow yeah Tarzan got out into
the woods and that's where he lived he
tried to survive in society he didn't
like it and so we went back into the
woods he was a feral child there's also
some feral child videos and this is
crazy to watch but there's one I know
I've seen on YouTube and maybe I'll try
to drop it into the the YouTube of my
own YouTube all of this past week in
this episode where there's a girl who
was raised by wild dogs and you can see
or drinking out of a faucet somewhere I
think in a faraway country and I thought
I want to say it's Eastern Europe but
I'll try to put that video into the
youtube as well you can you can check on
the YouTube of this past week in this
episode and see it that'll be up Monday
evening but do I think he was a virgin
when he met Jane I would bet no because
if you've been out in the wild and you
sing in all these animals you see them
having sex you know unlike me and Danny
you know we were watching from far away
with a magnifying glass and a binocular
but if you get up close and you're
witnessing that sexual action all the
time of animals you're gonna be curious
quick and I think you're gonna start
doing sex probably you may be what you
would think with monkeys and that's
where they say that aids started you
know I wouldn't be surprised
if I [ __ ] a monkey something bad should
happen I think you know cuz that's when
I think we're going a little too far I
don't think the monkey man we actually
monkeys probably you're into that
monkeys seem like animals some of them
the big ones that probably wouldn't mind
it you know but that definitely you know
I mean I've always said this about about
bestiality nobody wants to talk about it
right and I agree it's funky but here I
go if you're having sensual activity
with a small animal you you're going to
jail okay you're not just going to jail
in Arizona or Texas you're going to jail
everywhere far as I'm concerned but if
you are out there and you [ __ ] a
mountain lion or a Lynx you're a hero
okay you don't go to jail for that if
you're able to [ __ ] a cheetah you're
never buying a beer again you put that
on YouTube gazillion views that that'll
break the internet freaking you know
white dude bangs cheetah bro staying on
the back of a cheetah it'll put the
it'll put bull riding a shame like that
it'll put bull riding to shame like that
no saddle bareback Weiner only bro
that's the only thing connecting youth
to one of the craziest cats in the game
so Tarzan was your virgin when you met
Jane I you know but I think one of the
reasons and the beauty in the story of
Tarzan is that is that that's where I
learned about love so I'm guessing that
he probably was you know after read the
book again I'm not familiar but it's the
same guy that wrote John Carter which is
wild you know she just made that movie a
few years ago and that book Tarzan was
in like early 1900s early nineteen
hundred's Edgar Burroughs actually is a
man that wrote it where did aids start
dude started out there in the dark arts
something wild had to happen you know
something wild had to happen all right I
want to hit a few patreon questions here
from our patreon people I appreciate you
guys as supports from kee Jenkins yo I
just want to slowly get to know you
what's your favorite beverage my
favorite beverage since I don't drink
alcohol currently you know I'm 14 months
sober so I drink ginger beer that's what
I like and I also like water because if
I'm made of water guess what I'm giving
myself water don't be an idiot
you know I'm saying you out there
drinking milk dude I came out of an
animal so unless you got a wife or
somebody you know and they used to let
us breastfeed off my aunt when I was
young and that was you know a little
more kosher back then I don't know if
you know breast feeding off from your
aunt is I don't even if that's still
legal anymore who's doing that but it
used to be pretty popular when I was a
child but yeah I go with ginger beer or
water or my two choices another question
Theo loved the podcast you're a
wordsmith couple of questions do you
cook what would be your last meal I
don't cook very often occasionally I
will cook for my neighbors my neighbors
are very good to me and I love them and
they treat me well and sometimes I'll
get I'll make them some Cajun food and
I'll make a jambalaya or I'll make a
dessert I like a creme brulee what would
be my last meal you know I probably had
me a turkey avocado sandwich and I don't
put any mayonnaise on it I like to pour
a little bit olive oil some salt and
pepper on that thing and then I would
honestly sometime I like to just put
sugar in my mouth when I was young we
used to play this game where you put
sugar and in each other's mouths you
know would slap each other in the face
and try to knock that sugar out of
somebody's mouth and if you knocked the
sugar out of them then uh then you won
so that was a popular game back then and
so I probably had me maybe just a little
bit of sugar you know so I could go to
heaven with a little bit of sweetener on
my gums another question this is all
from Florida from Matthew Holland we
said I'm riding out the hurricane here
in Florida this [ __ ] is crazy
that's what Matthew said anyway in
sticking with the caloric intake theme
my question is as follows when was the
worst time I don't know what the caloric
intake theme is but when was the worst
time you ever bombed on stage and ate an
entire plate of dicks or Deacs
or [ __ ] I'll tell you when it was and
actually you're in Florida it was in
Florida I was working at University of
North Florida I was hosting a battle of
the bands that they had there and that's
where different bands compete each
against each other different college
bands compete against each other to see
who is the best even though they all
[ __ ] suck
and I was the maitre d the the announcer
for the evening so I came out and I had
to do stand-up I come out I do like 10
minutes of stand-up they boo me off the
stage now literally I've been doing
stand-up for three years they boo me off
the stage right boo me off but little do
they know I have to go back out between
every band and do five more minutes of
comedy I burned all my material right in
the beginning just burning through it
because I was it was like a dog in a
fight I just you know I wasn't even
grasping anything with my teeth but I
was still just biting at the air just
firing all my bullets at once and and I
and I screwed it you know I it was
horrible
and I had to go back out there I think
six more times at least and in between
the bands and I had no material and they
just from they let me up and I could
feel tears inside of my body gathering
and I never I never cried inside before
now I cried on the inside often you know
I was fill I put a lot of tears in me I
guess when I was born and it took over
the years they came out but as a as an
adult I hadn't really hit the tear bank
a ton and and I'd never hit the tear
Bank internally and you could just feel
just that salt water just running down
my insides and that was tears of
uncertainty and not of joy and that was
in your state in Florida another
question from our patreon supporter
Charlie Dunham says do HAMP's
reciprocate affection and loyalty I'll
say this when I was young they did and I
think I had more patience at the time
for hamsters he's talking about hamsters
and a lot of people know or don't know
that I grew up in a hamster breeding
area and I used to sell hamsters and G
pigs guinea pigs but and they used to
but I think
I had more patience for him and a lot of
the hamster market these days has it
come we get a lot of our hamsters from
Russia from Eastern Europe that's true
story
that's facts but guinea pigs those are
the ones that are more affectionate and
they're more beautiful looking to me
these days everybody has their opinion
but I like those that's your answer
there charlie I appreciate the question
and one more from Christian Prado hey
dude
just yesterday the car behind me at an
intersection got t-boned before my eyes
what's the craziest accident you've ever
witnessed either by your involvement or
as a bystander I know exactly what it
was I was in New Orleans and we were
down by down by the Mississippi we're
down my Mardi Gras world and a black man
just shot another black man in the back
he shot him in the back with a gun and
the guy that got who didn't the guy who
did the shooting he ran off and the guy
who didn't do the shooting got hit by
the bullet and just he looked not well
and then we drove off man you drive fast
you don't when people are getting shot
apparently I am I and my friend who was
driving we're not the type of people
that hang around so that's what we did
but I would say that's one of the
craziest accidents that I ever witnessed
I'm gonna think about that again in the
future and I got hit by a Trans Am when
I was a child I got hit by a beautiful
silver Trans Am there on 25th Street in
Covington Louisiana and I'll tell you
this it sucks getting hit by a car but
get hit get hit by a nice little hot rod
boy it makes it a little bit more
comfortable so those are our patreon
questions again you can support us on
patreon that's P a Treo n comm slash
Theo von and I appreciate everybody
who's given that support Oh what else do
we want to get into today guys I feel
like you know just this 911 stuff I
guess it's kind of sitting on me a
little bit and I appreciate you guys
being here with me to think about it and
just kind of you know just think about
you know what does it mean to be alive
you know what does it mean you know what
does it mean when you know your life kit
could end it could end in an instant and
then
what happens you know where do we go you
know I know that I'm going somewhere
else you know it might be a heaven it
might be somewhere special you know I
know that and I believe that and some
people don't like to believe in that
kind of stuff but here's what I'm saying
why wouldn't you what do you have to
lose are you afraid and at a certain
point I'm like having a little bit of
faith it's almost like you're afraid to
put your ball in this into a bigger
court I think it takes balls to have a
little bit of faith these days you know
it's and look we don't have a lot of
proof you know but I don't think we ever
had any proof we were gonna be here
you know I mean Joe Rogan says the best
floating on a ball of dirt and water you
know in the middle of nowhere and nobody
seems to care if it can happen once
again I could easily end up in a more
exotic place with beautiful animals like
chimpanzees and alpaca Keats you know in
sallem ayahs you know and this is that's
a salamander tiger and they small on the
front and they got a big hips and tiger
back in beautiful animals but that was
pretty much the weekend guys you know
that was pretty much the weekend and I
hope your weekend was good you know we
got a beautiful week ahead of us now
we're here in a September I'll be in
Cleveland
you can come there and check me out you
can hit the hotline with anything that
you know you want to think about or
discuss you know if you had if you have
this 911 meant something to you what's
going on you know I'll get in and fill
you in we're doing some new things here
at the podcast that patreon supports
gonna help out you know we don't have a
lot of followers yet but it'll come on
and I appreciate the people who got on
board and if you didn't get on board
that's okay too so yeah I think today's
theme is just to celebrate that life man
celebrate the fact that we're alive you
know because some people September 11th
that ended that was their last one well
we got this one we're here today for
this one you know we're here today and
I'll give you guys a sensual update I am
coming into five days of no masturbation
no pornography and may and I'll say this
it feels pretty good it feels pretty
good and we got some other great
we'll get into him next week we're gonna
post some other content this week I
appreciate everybody checking into this
past weekend I'll see you guys in
Cleveland and Oh next week I got a big
announcement to make so pretty excited
about that and let's take us out of here
with uh with what we love to do man just
to celebrate living happy September 11th
guys the number one thing you can do to
remember September 11th is to celebrate
living keep it going onward you know you
can show up to work drunk but you might
end up falling off the poop boat so you
stay on your poop boat cuz they got [ __ ]
out there in the water you guys be good
to yourselves and I'm gonna try to be
good to myself and we're gonna make it
through one more week together man I'll
see you guys next weekend I love you
crispy little criminals man I'm gonna
try to go not masturbate and go to sleep
Monday Night Football tomorrow night
baby my saints I'm excited all right you
guys take care man thank you
[Music]
you